laia wathah Elizabeth Warren has finally
released a DNA test proving that she's
SuperDuper white we will analyze Foca
Honda's new presidential campaign slogan
Elizabeth Warren vote for one xx xx in
2020 then fake news dozen other fake
news president Trump dunks on Lesley
Stahl and how transgender is a broke
political correctness
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I work today I didn't you know this news
about Liz Warren's DNA test about her
Indian ancestry this just broke this
morning I didn't know last night when I
put my head on my little purple mattress
you know I didn't know I thought what
are we gonna talk about tomorrow I wake
up today sweet little ELISA nudges me
she goes Mac Mac Elizabeth Warren wrote
your show today Mac thought oh that's so
nice thank you liya whathe
we this is this is truly illustrative of
how deluded the left is right now how
deluded Democrats are right now that
they are celebrating Liz Warren's test
as a victory
Liz Warren's tests proving that she is
nearly 100% white as a victory we'll get
to that in a second first got to make a
little money honey let's thank bamboo HR
you know bamboo HR if you have your own
smaller medium-sized business or if you
work in HR you know how crazy it can be
when I was hired at the Daily wire they
had to hire an entire army of HR
specialists obviously you have miles of
spreadsheets time off to manage
never-ending paperwork countless random
employee issues the stress is huge and
it leaves no time to do what you love
such as working with people and making
your business better this is where
bamboo HR can help bamboo HR managers
all your employee data and automates the
countless tasks that you have to deal
with I have worked and worked on a lot
of campaigns I've worked in small
businesses I've worked here when this
was a small business though that kind of
paperwork those kind of compliance tasks
and HR tasks can really derail people
from doing what they want to do what
they need to do to make their company
grow let H a bamboo HR figure this out
for you it's a really good all your
employee information record-keeping
managed in one place East signatures
onboarding paperwork all of that there
are no long term contracts or
commitments right now bamboo HR is
giving my listeners a special extended
free trial that's right instead of their
standard step seven-day trial that's for
the like the plebeians that's not for
michael null show listeners you can try
out bamboo HR for a full 14 days the
only way to get this special offer is to
go to bamboo HR comm / co FFA co v fe fe
just type it in it's fun to type bamboo
HR comm / co FFA for this exclusive
extended free trial go to bamboo HR com
/ Co FF a limited time offer just for my
listeners Benbow
George calm /co fedfe one more time you
know what it is bamboo HR calm / co' FFA
Foca haunt us has done it you know
president Trump challenge sir he said
I'll donate a million dollars to a
charity of your choice
if you take a DNA test that proves that
you're a Native American so she took the
DNA test and it didn't go the way that
she wanted I think it proves that she's
almost entirely white the Ted that so
99.9% chance she's white the test did
show the possibility that she has a
smidgen of Native American ancestry at
the very most 1/32 Native American and
perhaps more likely closer to 1,000 24th
Native American well she is less than
1/1000 Native American possibly
according to this test and the DNC and
the Liz Warren campaign and the left is
releasing this as though it is a victory
and I we actually have exclusive footage
from inside the Liz Warren campaign
headquarters inside the Democratic
National Committee headquarters to see
why they're releasing this as a victory
people made fun of me for being French
DNA and me showed I was 8 percent Navajo
nobody's making fun of me now or my
people who are victims I'm thirteen
percent victim 21 victim order now and
find out if your friend should be more
sympathetic order now is that a new
sponsor a ridiculous that find out of
you are a victim the victim identifier
that is what Liz Warren is so happy
about so you know I thought that I was
just a coddled a white woman white as
can be her Harvard employee you know
traded on my fake ancestry to gain a
professional advantage you know now a
member of the United States Senate but
really I'm a victim really Liz Warren is
a victim that is the this is the Boston
Globe story we've got to get into this
because the the way that the left is
reacting is lunacy Boston Globe comes
out they say quote senator Elizabeth
Warren has released a DNA test that
provides strong evidence she had a
Native American in her family tree
dating back
to ten generations an unprecedented move
by one of the top possible contenders
for the 2020 Democratic nomination for
president and this is very important
this is unprecedented because it shows
how insane the left has gotten about
their racism about their race obsession
they are now releasing tests that show
that they have one one thousandth Native
American blood they see I'm to see I'm
on that race I'm that race that race
matters that's what I'm gonna win that
is unprecedented that is bizarre that
we're now releasing our racial pedigrees
when we're running for public office
that not not in 70 years or so have we
seen that in a developed country that is
pretty crazy and it's the Democrats
doing it all in the name of
progressivism the piece goes on Warren
whose claims to Native American blood
have been mocked by President Trump and
other Republicans provided the test
results to the globe on Sunday in an
effort to defuse questions about her
ancestry that have persisted for years
she planned an elaborate rollout Monday
of the results as she aimed for
widespread attention this is like that
scene you know that Jim Carrey clip
where I think it was him Dumb and Dumber
where the girl is like I will never date
you you're awful I hate you no no no and
he just look so he goes so you're saying
there's a chance that that is Liz Warren
opening these test results all right
give it to me straight doctor well Liz
you're between ninety six point nine and
ninety-nine point nine percent white so
you're saying there's a chance
you're saying there's a chance I'm
Cherokee that is absurd this was done by
Carlos Bustamante Stanford University
geneticist I am trying to analyze just
for you how the left possibly thinks
that this is a win because it's even it
see the news news reporters got the
number wrong they initially thought it
was between 1/32 and one 500th I think
Indian now if they've revised that to
one thirty second to one one thousandth
Indian also Native American DNA is
notoriously unreliable in these tests
the reason for that is that Native
Americans don't take these tests one
because
they don't care they know that they're
Native American and too because you know
Native Americans have been treated a
little rough in this country from time
to time so they don't they don't want to
give over their their DNA to these guys
the the important statistic here is not
1/32 it's not one 1,024 it's not
whatever the average European American
is 1.8% Indian Native American American
indigenous whatever euphemism you want
to use that's the average white American
has 1.8% Indian in them
Liz Warren has almost that exact same
amount possibly significantly less it
would be it would mean that virtually
every white member of the United States
Senate Congress running for president
could say I'm an Indian I'm Cherokee
prove that I'm not because don't forget
Liz Warren used this for professional
benefit she says that she didn't fact
check her left-wing commentary websites
say that she didn't she did she
certainly did we'll get into that in a
second
I my first thought on this was what was
she thinking and I'm not the only one
and this is not just a partisan reaction
Jim Messina who was Barack Obama's
campaign chairman he also was furious
he's tweeting and who's saying what are
you thinking 22 days before an important
election the midterm elections Liz
Warren is doubling down on this absurd
claim that she's an Indian telling you
not to believe your lying eyes because
she's one one-thousandth Native American
what are you thinking Liz word after the
Cavanaugh effect that's already killing
Democrats and swing races Liz Warren
comes down and says yeah but really I'm
chief Lyle Wafaa give me a break so so
Jim Jim Messina and I agree on this we
don't agree on much but we agree on that
Liz Warren needs less attention on her
ancestry I know you know what it is it's
that President Trump gets in the heads
of his opponents because he's so brash
and infuriating cuz he's like a little
schoolyard bully who's holding Liz
Warren's like stalks of corn and wampum
I don't know I'm trying to make an
analogy here she's holding it he's
holding it above her head and she's
saying I'm real I am Native American
you're not you're Pocahontas I am Native
America and he's he's driving them
if she were thinking clearly here if she
were thinking rationally she would not
take a test she would not make a big
news story about it she would not do any
of that what she is thinking is that
this issue is dogged her in her career
it might prevent her from being
successful in 2020 president Trump has
forever branded her Pocahontas
so she what she is thinking is right now
even before the midterms I'm gonna get
this story out there
my personal Pravda the Boston Globe is
gonna run with it and they're going to
cover for me in all of the media are
gonna cover for me and then when it
comes up again the next time President
Trump calls me Pocahontas in six months
I can say I took a test and it proves
I'm Native American that's not how this
is gonna play out that is not how this
is going to play out President Trump is
gonna have a field day with this I hope
he has a field day with this he hasn't
really gotten too into it yet I hope
he's just he's just you know testing out
the tweets he's trying he's massaging it
like a poet with the you know with his
meter and his rhyme scheme trying to get
the tweets right this has no upside for
Liz Warren how are you gonna react to
this so Liz Warren claims for her
professional career that she's Native
American not even just like part Native
American she's listed in the Harvard
directory is Native American she
contributes a recipe to a Native
American cookbook called powwow Chow as
Elizabeth Warren Cherokee not Elizabeth
Warren 99.9% generic white possibly
point 1% Cherokee been probably not even
that just Elizabeth Warren Cherokee so
she's been Duke using this for her
entire academic career and then she says
no no I wasn't lying see I'm 1/1000 that
Native American who is that gonna
convince conservatives obviously you're
gonna have to laugh at that as we've
been doing all day
but or is that going to convince
moderates is that gonna convince
independence you say oh well you know I
thought she was lying about being Native
American but she's one one-thousandth so
I don't know I'm I must be like one
one-thousandth sub-saharan African right
somewhere especially Italy and a lot of
people are moving around and Sicily in
the in the good old days does that
doesn't make me a black guy doesn't I
don't I don't get to say certain words I
don't get to sing certain songs
that are politically incorrect and
offensive absolutely not of course not
and this doesn't make her in Indian but
even among the left because I think what
she's thinking right now is okay I'm
going to at least give myself this data
point that I can always point back to
before the 2020 primaries heat up and
I'm going to give leftist progressives
an excuse not to hate me I'm gonna give
the race obsessed laughs an excuse not
to hate me is that really gonna work
because now they know now they know that
she's 99.9% white before we all
everybody knew it but there was this
kind of you could just pretend say well
we don't know she never took a test she
could be Indian we just don't know and
she doesn't look Indian but we don't
know now we know it's like the monster
in a horror movie you know when you when
you're watching a horror movie and the
monster the killer is off screen you
fill it with whatever you want to see
you fill it with your imagination and it
really works when you see the monster
it's always a letdown because it can't
live up to your expectations that is how
the race obsessed left the activists
that Liz Warren is trying to appeal to
here that's what they're gonna see
because the reality is going to
disappoint them it already has before we
get any further with this let me tell
you about something that doesn't
disappoint me black rifle coffee make a
little money honey if you have ever
found yourself wincing at the weak taste
of coffee from those left-leaning soy
corporate brands you know the ones that
have become homeless shelters in recent
days because of ridiculous PR stones I
don't know I'm just the ones that maybe
come from the city of Seattle I don't
know I'm just I don't want to name any
other brand you've probably thought I
wish they spent less time on meaningless
bias training bathroom policy reform
donating to Planned Parenthood all that
other stuff that defies common sense a
more time on their coffee that's why you
need black rifle coffee founded by
former Special Operations veterans black
rifle delivers the best roasts to order
coffee right to your door I gotta tell
you I would probably buy it just to
support veterans first responder causes
because they're not politically correct
wackos yeah but what actually matters to
me is just how good the coffee is the
coffee is excellent you cannot beat the
coffee it is superb I drink it all
time mmm I'm sorry that was left us
tears yeah I also have coffee out of
that too though this guarantees you're
getting fresh premium coffee with every
order in addition to great coffee and
gear black rifle as a coffee club that
makes things easy they also give a
portion of their sales to veteran and
first responder causes so that's a
wonderful thing to visit black rifle
coffee I'm slash cough fa c OV e fe fe
you're gonna want a little bit of both
in your day little coffee a little cough
fa you can have one without the other
receive 15% off your order black rifle
coffee calm slash cough fa co v fe fe
for 15% off black rifle coffee calm / co
FFA go get it it's very very delicious
so i think this is gonna backfire
because in the intersectional left just
like in that commercial you know I'm a
victim I'm one thirty-second victim I'm
one 1000th victim you're if you're a
white lady from Harvard you're gonna
lose that battle eventually and now we
have the data point now when she says we
don't know I might be Native American
you say you're not you're one
one-thousandth Native American maybe
maybe not even that
I think that's gonna really hurt her
also I would like to point out identity
politics doesn't work for Native
Americans because there aren't enough of
them so I think I think they're kind of
believing their own press releases
they're believing some of the stuff that
they're putting out there in their
advertisements and this is an important
lesson one of the best pieces of advice
I ever got from my mother is don't
believe your own press releases don't
believe the stuff that you were saying
just to kind of puff up your activities
or puff up your campaign or but don't
don't fall into the trap of believing
that yourself
I think she's believing that she thinks
if I can claim even one one-millionth
Native American ancestry I'll get that
victim point you won't the the appeal of
racial identity politics which the left
has totally embraced for decades now the
appeal is a brutal appeal it's not an
ideological appeal it's not a
philosophical appeal it is brutal it
gets to our very basic animal instincts
which is you look like me uh you look
like you I'll vote for you
that's the appeal that they're making
and it's it's pretty cheap and it's
pretty tawdry and it's not a human or
humanistic or elevated appeal
but it only works if you look like the
person it only the identity appeal only
works if you can say yeah I'm gonna help
out black people specifically and that
other guy hates black people and I'm
gonna help out Hispanics specifically
and the other guys hate Hispanics and
only if you're appealing directly that
group what's the appeal for Native
Americans what what argument is she
making on behalf of Native Americans how
many are going to swing the vote at
least in certain municipalities if you
can actually appeal to race and you can
get racial groups to vote as a bloc then
you can then it works it at least pays
off at the ballot box that doesn't work
for Native Americans its shoes must be
kicking herself that she doesn't have
some you know more more populist racial
minority group that she could cynically
try to play on the other the other
reason this doesn't work for Democrats
is it reminds American voters of the
Democrats terrible history so this is
not going to be as bad in effect as the
rest of them but it reminds voters of
the one-drop rule which is this racist
Democrat policy from the 19th and 20th
centuries that if you had even one
little teensy drop of black heritage in
you then you were black for purposes of
the law and therefore you were a
second-class citizen that that's
obviously a racist idea
it's a creates racial hierarchies that
do not and should not exist and she's
buying into that a century later for her
Native American lies because what a
tangled web we leave when we when we
practice to conceive when we practiced
oh that's know that that was a Freudian
slip a Freudian slip is where you say
one thing I mean your mother what a
tangled web we weave when we practice to
deceive
and that's what Liz Warren has done she
told this lie in the 1980s she was
becoming a professor she switched from
white ethnicity to Indian Native
American ethnicity this as she
contributed you know recipes to that
cookbook and Harvard touted this for her
they said we have a Native American on
staff she's been covering up for that
lie ever since and this evidence today
exposes that lie even more just putting
aside all of that ugliness does she
really think this quells the issue
that people gonna say okay well okay one
one-thousandth of course not this is
more fodder and she's using this to
galvanize the left does she not think
her primary opponents in 2020 on the
left are gonna use this does she not
realize that Kamala Harris Cory Booker
Joe Biden all of these guys are gonna
clobber her with this it's not she is
not the leader in this presidential race
right now if anybody is probably Joe
Biden is because Barack Obama might
support him if there's a breakout star
right now she is not the leader she
cannot play it as though she's the the
nominee she's got to play really hard
punch really hard and she's not doing it
why did she do it I think she did it
because Trump makes people expose who
they are he makes people exposed to they
really are you know I I remember this
vividly in the 2016 primaries there was
that moment on stage where President
Trump he's talking to Jeb Bush he's
prodding Jeb Bush and Jeb Bush says
something that you know he thought
Donald would approve of and Donald puts
his hand out there and Bush smacks it
gives him a weird like awkward high-five
and this killed Jeb Bush because Jeb
Bush had been running on I am this
serious mature confident person in the
room very sober but now he was a case
politician like everybody else and
president Trump exposed that when he
when he did is like yeehaw
you know jump up in smack Trump's hand
it exposed him is not really being more
stable not really being more mature than
anybody else he might have held a
Shepley glass the right way but it
exposed that lie he does it everybody
did it to Hillary when he'll when he had
a prodded Hillary Clinton into calling
half the country deplorable and
irredeemable she exposed who she was the
Democrats now we're admitting to being a
mob because they hate Trump so much they
say yeah you bet we want to go clobber
them at their house were their children
sleep in restaurants you bet we're gonna
go out there and get them
so he's forcing them to admit who they
are and Liz Warren is doing that too and
unfortunately for Liz Walker and she's
an old white lady this is the difference
between Democrats and Republicans here
because what are the Republicans talking
about in their strategy sessions they
say we're gonna go hard on political
correctness we'll get to that in a
second later we're gonna go hard on
immigration we're gonna go hard on
the economic prosperity the virtual
extinction of unemployment the relative
peace around the world that's we're
gonna campaign on in this election what
are the Democrats thinking thinking hmm
is 132nd enough is that is one
one-thousandth enough by the way it's
not for membership in these Indian
tribes usually you need one quarter
Indian heritage that's for most tribes
some you can go down to 1/16 I think the
eastern Cherokees allow you to go down
to 1/16 and the Cherokee Nation says
there's no limit there's no minimum but
you do have to be able to document it
she doesn't have any of that
Liz Warren doesn't have doesn't meet any
of those requirements she would be
rejected for membership even though she
contributed powwow chow to that to that
cookbook that is the reality of this and
I'm one unless than 1/1000 the Native
American is not an answer the other
political error that she's making here
is she doesn't realize that when you're
explaining you're losing so Ronald
Reagan articulated this very well when
you are explaining in politics you are
losing what do you mean by that well in
politics sometimes the best defense is a
good offense Trump is a good example
Brett Kavanaugh is a good example when
you punch back really hard it disorients
your opponent but when you're explaining
you've already given up the argument if
somebody says to you when did you stop
beating your wife you say well what well
what did you did you talk to my wife my
wife will tell you that that I didn't
beat her and I Bubba and you've already
lost because you've accepted the premise
that they're giving you when you're
explaining you're losing sometimes it's
true the premise that Liz Warren is
fighting against here is that she's a
liar and a fraud and inauthentic that's
true she's not gonna win by fighting
that that's true she's a fraud she's not
gonna win by explaining why she's not
affront she's got to hit something else
she's got to talk about I don't know
healthcare or whatever other or you know
soaking the rich
I think his faith medicare-for-all I
don't know is she's got to run on her
socialist program that's the only way
she has a chance if she's fighting on
the terms of this premise that she's a
she's not really inauthentic she's not
really a fraud she's going to lose
president Trump uses this to great
effect when you're explaining you're
losing so you always punch back if you
saw this sixty minutes interview it was
superb
don't take my word for it cuz obviously
I'm a little biased I like the president
variety admitted this a left-wing
Hollywood publication variety said quote
sixty minutes outmatched by Donald Trump
here's a clip of him talking to Lesley
Stahl you go out and you go to
Mississippi
the famous Mississippi speech I had one
beer well you think was shooting up that
was one beer oh good
how did you get home I don't remember
how'd you get there don't remember where
is the place I don't remember how many
years ago was it I don't know and you
mimicked professor blase Ford you
mimicked her had I not made that speech
we would not have won I was just saying
she didn't seem to know anything and
you're trying to destroy a life of a man
who has been extraordinary why did you
have to make fun of her I didn't really
make fun well they were what I said is
the person that we're talking about
didn't know the year the time the place
professor Blasi Ford got before the
Senate and and was asked what's the
worst moment she said when the two boys
laughed at me at my expense and then I
watched you mimic her and thousands of
people were laughing at her they can do
what they tell you the way now justice
Kavanagh was traded has become a big
factor in the midterms have you seen
what's gone on with the polls but did
you have to well I think she was treated
with great respect I'll be honest what
do you think there were those things you
shouldn't do you think you treated her
with great I think so yeah I did but you
seem to be saying that she lied what you
know what I'm not gonna get into it
because we won it doesn't matter
we won did you see there is so much in
that clip there actually it's an I mean
it's typical you know Trump bluster but
there is a lot of rhetoric to realize
there and it's all on this when you're
explaining you're losing so she brings
it up she says you mocked you made fun
of Christine Ford you
that lady who could changed her story a
thousand times and discovered these 30
year old memories after the fact at the
11th hour that you know that lady you
made fun of of Christine Ford and so his
first reaction is now I didn't really
make fun of her so his first reaction is
denial it's a very New York thing deny
till you die so his first reaction is
denial and then she shows the clip and
she goes on and but you you you made fun
of her why did you make fun of her now
what a less skilled media operative or a
less skilled politician would have done
there is it I didn't I didn't really
make fun of her I said hypothetically I
just pointed out you know that testimony
and but I wasn't making fun of her I was
violence define the word fun and define
making and well it depends on what the
definition you know know what he does is
he realizes where this is going
if it were just one question they could
move on but he realizes that Lesley
Stahl of 60 minutes is gonna try to nail
him on this point and just drill it
until he says something stupid and
they're gonna run with that so what does
he do
he immediately turns it to Cavanaugh he
says look the way Kavanaugh was treated
of very he even takes that little beat
you can see it turn Cavanaugh was
treated very unfairly what they did to
Cavanaugh was so awful so he changes it
he moves the topic into a new direction
and then she says but I want to get back
to talking about how you made fun of her
didn't you didn't you make fun of her
and he says absolutely not no I didn't
do you notice the difference there at
first he said I didn't really make fun
of her - I did not make fun of her -
then she says no didn't show though and
he says I treated her with great respect
I think I treated her with great respect
with just within that answer now you
might say he is sort of contradict one
another they don't quite contradict one
another but you are seeing rhetorical
strategies change as he's getting where
this is going and he is fighting he is
punching right back because I think I
treated her respectfully yeah I think I
treated her respectfully and Lesley
Stahl still pushes it so she's just
there hectoring I'm just badgering him
and so finally he says well we won
doesn't really matter now does it
because we got him on the court so yeah
keep trying because we still on the
court and that that were I think that
really shows you a lot about how we
should handle politics through the
midterms and afterward
they are not that's not an honest
question were you making fun of her you
were making fun of her were you making
fun of her that's not an honest question
that is a line of attack so you've got
you can't counter that line of attack by
trying to explain why you weren't really
making fun of her he denied it he hit
hard and then he changed the topic he
moved on he blew right past it
you know Antonin Scalia in an interview
with Lesley Stahl and was the exact same
setup he had a similar interaction with
her where she said you say Justice
Scalia the torture isn't cruel and
unusual punishment and he says yeah
that's right she goes well if you're
trying to get information out of a
terrorist is that yeah right if you're
trying to get information that's not
punishment then you're trying to get
information how is that punishment
because well you know because you're a
terrorist and and she just keeps pushing
just keep saying it's cruel and unusual
it's cruel and unusual it's cruel and
unusual punishment and finally he just
cuts her off and he says well that's my
view and it happens to be correct which
is a line that I now use constantly you
know whenever you really ever you get to
the end of an argument said well that's
my view and it happens to be correct and
president Trump realizes this too I
think Republicans should get it you know
I saw Jeff Flake today was getting
squishy again I know shock also water is
wet in the sky is blue in the Sun shines
and Jeff Flake said well we shouldn't
have spiked the football over Cavanagh
spike that football I want I want parrot
jumpers you know out of helicopters and
out of airplanes to grab a football not
deploy their parachute and just dive it
right into the dirt I want it to go
halfway through the core of the earth
spike that football it teaches them a
lesson this is a bare knuckle moment and
we can't have people who don't
understand them so then there's more
fake news I know you'll be shocked to
find that out the fake news this weekend
was particularly egregious NBC tweeted
this out they said quote watch president
Trump says that Robert Ely was a great
general during ohio rally calling the
Confederate leader incredible incredible
not just great general you incredible
now here's the clip that they posted
with President Trump it also gave you
a general who was incredible
he drank a little bit too much you know
who I'm talking about right so robert e
lee was a great general and abraham
lincoln developed a phobia he couldn't
beat robert e lee he was going crazy
couldn't be robert e lee okay ultra so
you heard that you heard that begin that
was the whole clip that they posted the
trouble with their tweet is it that it
was completely incorrect they tweeted
out feel like a Herman Cain Herman Cain
during one of the debates in 2012 some
Bloomberg reporter said mister Cain
we've analyzed your tax plan and it'll
cost the government way too much money
and he said well the problem with your
analysis is that it is incorrect that's
the the problem with your tweet NBC is
that it is incorrect so it week
correction an earlier tweet
misidentified the general president
Trump described as incredible at a rally
in Ohio it was general ulysses s grant
not general robert e lee it was the
opposite general it was the good guy not
the bad guy they go on an attached video
clip lacked the full context for trump's
remark here is the Folklife here's the
full clip they didn't know how and one
day it was looking really bad and
lincoln just said you hardly knew his
name and they said don't take him he's
got a drinking problem and lincoln said
I don't care what problem he has you
guys aren't winning and his name was
Grant General Grant
and his name was grant general grant you
heard that the set up on the incredible
general in that first clip was he had a
drinking problem the payoff in this clip
is he had a drinking problem but he was
an incredible general ulysses s grant so
they finally released that how long do
you think it took NB c-- news to correct
that story and and by correct i mean
completely reverse it completely reverse
it that you remember there was a study a
few years ago that came out some
psychology study that said that
conservatives are much more likely to be
authoritarian than leftists and then
years later they corrected that and they
said Oh actually it's the opposite Oh
actually the leftists or authoritarian
sorry we forgot it was opposite day when
we released the video so I guess it was
opposite day when NBC News released that
clip how long do you think it took them
to to correct that 5 minutes 10 minutes
10 minutes on Twitter's a long time two
hours two days two days it took them are
we to suspect that they didn't watch the
clip I don't know maybe they watched the
clip that they don't understand how
language works that's perfectly
plausible it took them two days that why
because they're dishonest they always
run the the fake story on page one and
then the the correction on page 377 in
this clip by the way tells us a lot
about Donald Trump I'll tell you what it
tells us in a second plus we've got to
get on to how MIT Romney never learns
anything some important polls for the
midterm elections and then I think I've
discovered the straw that broke the
camel's back of political correctness I
think I've discovered the end of
political correctness but first we've
got to say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube you go to daily wire calm and by
the way if you join daily wire right now
you will get early access to another
Kingdom that's the podcast that I'm
doing with Andrew Clavin he wrote the
whole thing I read it it's been
Illustrated it's got this incredible
artwork now cool sets and it's drew
story its second season first season was
very popular this one is even cooler you
will get that on Mondays and you'll get
to watch the whole thing if you are a
subscriber if you're not a subscriber
you got to wait until Friday and then
you just get to listen to it
that's terrible don't do that go do it
go to daily wire calm it's ten bucks a
month $100 for an annual membership you
get me you get the under Clavin sure you
get the bench piercer you have questions
the mailbag you test questions in the
conversation but then you get this you
get the leftist here's tumblr which
contains heap big leftist tears these
days heap big leftist tears this is this
has sustained my ancestors for
generations and generations the great
spirit of the leftist tears has moved
from plane to plane as the Knowles
family has moved across this great
country and it can sustain you too this
is at look you know I'm a Native
American I was born in America this is a
little native secret that I've uncovered
is the leftist years it will sustain you
will bring you joy all the days of your
life go to daily wire calm we'll be
right back with a lot more
this clip tells us a lot about Donald
Trump because he's talking about Ulysses
s screen he says look there was this
incredible guy but he had a drinking
problem and so they didn't they didn't
pick him then the Lincoln had this
trouble because the Confederate General
Robert E Lee was a great general and he
kept winning with victory after victory
and Lincoln picked all the guys who
looked like the good generals all the
guys who should have been the good
generals you know they they had the
right cut of their jib and they talked
good and they went to West Point and
they they all should have been great
generals but they kept losing to robert
e lee and so lincoln took a little look
over at that alcoholic that guy or the
drinking problem ulysses s grant and he
picked him and he said i don't care if
he's got a drinking problem he can win
he can fight and he can win I'll put the
historical seriousness of that story
aside and just listen to Trump telling
that story he's talking about himself
and this is actually pretty self
effacing one of the things about Trump
is he's this big ego right he's always
talking Trump is on every building that
he's ever walked by he's plastered his
name on it this is pretty self effacing
because he's comparing himself to an
alcoholic he's saying look I know I
don't look like the tough conservative
president I know I don't sound like him
I don't talk like the president I don't
talk like the guy who can fix the
economy bring peace around the world you
know fix some wars here and there we
renegotiate a tree I know I don't talk
like that guy and I don't look like that
guy and I've got my own flaws but
sometimes that's just the guy who can
get it done and I think he's absolutely
right and and some more evidence for
this is that he said this before they
were talking about Brett Cavanaugh's
beer-drinking you know I like beer I
still like beer I drink beer I like beer
and Trump said you know I'm basically
the only politician in the world who can
say I've never had a beer I've just
never I've never had a beer and imagine
if I did I would be the worst the only
good thing about me is that I don't
drink now this is quote was almost
almost word-for-word his quote and that
was self effacing means he's got a sense
of his own flaws and he's a very flawed
guy no question about it but for him to
talk like this at a rally is pretty
impressive to me
it actually shows me that he understands
his place not just in the Republican
Party not just in the American
government but also in history that he's
the guy who goes in and just the
unlikely fixer
he's the unlikely guy that you'd never
pick in ideal circumstances you'd always
pick the guys who look like they should
win except they can't win so you picked
that guy and maybe he can pull you pull
you out of victory I'm really impressed
when I see these things sometimes I
worry you know that he really is the
caricature that the left makes him out
to be but then he keeps getting stuff
right so I don't believe that and I
really you know I trust my lyin eyes
before I trust the lying New York Times
compare him compare that line to Mitt
Romney who we've talked about I think
months ago on the show we talked about
him Mitt Romney can't learn anything
Donald Trump does learn things but Mitt
Romney just can't he never learns
anything here is some you know lefty
comes up approaches Romney with a camera
and tries to get Romney on the record
talking about I mean maybe it was a
right-winger I don't know talking about
never Trump you know President Trump is
you know or rather Mitt Romney is going
to go to the United States Senate he's
gonna have to work with Trump so whoever
it is left or right winger has the
camera there and you hear this question
come out from you know all the other
press who are there with the microphones
and they say what about never Trump
here's his answer
well I don't think that was the case the
President Trump was not the person I
wanted to become the nominee of our
party but he's president now the
policies he's promoted have been pretty
effective and I support a lot of those
policies when that then there's a place
where I disagree I point that out but
right now we're in a race to say are we
going to have a nation that is going to
be guided by conservative principles
where we get a dick a sharp turn left
turn left vote any conservative
principles work and that's my people I
think are given get behind martha
mcsalley and across Republican
suppression getting you there's the Mitt
Romney answer there it is they say you
were the leader of never Trump he was
the leader of never Trump Mitt Romney
was the former presidential nominee of
the Republican Party he came out he
called Trump a liar and a fraud he said
his promises are worth as worthless as a
degree from Trump University by the way
it turns out President Trump has kept
more promises than virtually any
president in recent history and but he
came out of me he gave that speech that
blistering speech against Donald Trump
and and he didn't vote for Donald Trump
he was the face of the true never Trump
movement and now what does he say well I
wasn't the head of never Trump I never
what are you talking about never
troubles I never never Trump I'm gonna
never never it from this reminds me he
did this exact thing in 1994 when he was
running for Senate in Massachusetts he
was asked about the record of Ronald
Reagan Ronald Reagan and you know in the
1980s Reagan Bush here's his answer look
I was an independent during the time of
Reagan Bush I'm not trying to return to
Reagan Bush same thing I was an
independent during the time of Reagan
but I'm not trying to return to Reagan
Bush I was an independent during the
time I've never Trump I'm not trying to
return to never Trump look Mitt Romney
comes from the squishy wing of the
Republican Party his father George
Romney came from that same wing the
liberal you know kind of consensus
middle part of the Republican Party but
he always pretends to be something
different when he's running for office
Mitt Romney invented Obamacare he was
the governor who installed Obamacare in
his state and then he tried to pretend
that he wasn't he's always running away
from who he is it's the same problem
that Liz Warren has I don't mean to beat
up on Mitt Romney I'm sure he's a good
guy but he just is so bad at this like
he's so wrong on
one issue be who you are if he if they
had said well you know you lead never
Trump what do you think now if they said
that Tim and he said look yeah I was
really anti Trump never Trump and then
it turned out he's been a very good
president yeah I guess I was wrong I'm
glad I got that one wrong and I can't
wait to continue this great conservative
success when I'm in the US Senate that
would be a great answer still be a
little skeptical of Romney but at least
he's being honest at least he's being
authentic but what he looks me in the
eye and he tells me that reality isn't
as it is if in that 94 election he
thought that being a conservative was a
risk in that 94 election against Ted
Kennedy guess what he lost the election
of course he lost the election but if he
came out here they said what do you
think of Reagan Bush and he said I
thought things went great during Reagan
Bush and I think the reason that we're
we've seen an economic boost is because
of the policies of Reagan Bush and I
think we defeated the Soviet Union which
by that time had been defeated because
of Reagan Bush yeah if returning to
Reagan Bush means winning the Cold War
and having peace and prosperity you're
damn right I'm a supporter of Reagan
Bush if he had said that he would have
had a fighting chance if you stand in
the middle of the road you are going to
get hit by a truck this is a fact of
politics he's doing the same thing again
he's gonna win this sentence eat but
it's really frustrating it's really
really unfortunate
speaking of polls by the way before we
get on to the cause of the death of
political correctness I want to point
out an important poll that matters no
I'm not talking about Missouri no I'm
not talking about Indiana no I'm not
talking about Texas all of which show
significant movement in the direction of
the Republican candidate after Brett
Kavanaugh I'm not talking I'm talking
about first man you saw this movie with
Damien Chazelle came out over the
weekend and you know Ryan Gosling movie
about Neil Armstrong landing on the moon
and it's one of these blockbuster Oscar
bait movies and it flopped at the box
office now there had been some
controversy with this movie because they
don't shown the alarm strong planting
the flag on the moon why didn't they do
that I don't know I sort of suspect it's
because they want to cozy up to Chinese
audiences and overseas audiences which
you're going to constitute a lot of it's
profit but Ryan Gosling did an interview
and he said oh you know it's
was a human achievement it's not an
American achievement and this really
irritated half the country so is
watching these box office returns pretty
closely because I thought you know if
this is a monster win at the box office
conservatives aren't as influential as I
thought we were concert' the the raw
feeling of patriotism wouldn't be as big
and this thing flopped it only made I
think what is it sixteen million over
the week sixteen seventeen million
should have made a lot more money than
that that's an important poll polls are
notoriously unreliable especially
generic polls especially national polls
I think that polls pretty reliable this
movie should have been a hit the only
explanation I can come up with is that
Americans don't want to see Hollywood
disrespect them anymore they don't want
to see elites disrespect them anymore
they don't want to be pushed around
twenty-two days until the election
that's an important data point and I I
think I know why the tide turned there
was this study that came out at the end
of last week
it showed that eighty percent of
Americans oppose political correctness
they think that it's a danger to the
country
eighty percent this is an all-time high
in the 1990s the number was fifty three
percent opposed PC and then it rose even
as late as 2016 polls put it about
seventy three percent now it's up to 80
percent consider political correctness a
serious problem in the country why is
that I think the answer is
transgenderism I actually think that's
the one that put it over because you
know it's one thing to say you have to
say happy holidays instead of Merry
Christmas my roll your eyes you say man
that's stupid I mean it's the holidays
Christmas but we're all right whatever
it's quite another thing to follow a
guy's daughter into the changing room at
the swimming pool because you say that
men can be women and women can be men
that's a very different thing
sex is essential to our identities in
the beginning God created man male and
female he created them this is a raw
part of us we've got a lot of hormones
pumping through our body the attraction
for men to women and women to men is
essential to the human condition
it's enjoyed by at least 97 or 98
percent of the population it's it it
really matters it really moves people I
think that's what this
about there was a story that came out
from the women's cycling tournament the
UCI masters Track Cycling World
Championship this transgender dude who
now is pretending to be a woman won the
Women's Championship surprise surprise
Rachel McKinnon is the name Rachel
McKinnon tweets out quote lots of
transphobic bigots are responding to my
world championship wins saying
next up the Paralympics hey women you
realize all these people many of them
women are comparing you to disabled
people right Wow offensive because this
person this guy Rachel McKinnon is
trying to distract from the fact that he
a man with a biological advantage took a
prize away from women who should have
won because it's a women's competition
because it's a women's competition he
actually or look we've been predicting
this forever and it's happened
frequently too he actually responded
because people said look you have a
biological advantage he said quote
focusing on performance advantage is
largely irrelevant because this is a
rights issue we shouldn't be worried
about trans people taking over the
Olympics we should be worried about
their fairness and human rights instead
but it's a sports competition sports
competition is about physical prowess he
says that people are comparing women to
the disabled in the analogy about the
Paralympics women do have a handicap
there is a handicap when men are
competing against women men are stronger
this guy Rachel MacKinnon tweeted out he
said we don't know why men do better at
sports than women we don't know it's
really complicated it's not complicated
men are stronger than women that's why
even because then their response is
always well Michael you're not exactly
an Adonis you're not a strong guy you're
not physically fit right I know I could
still beat up virtually any woman I
don't want to I never want to do that
god forbid I that ever happens I'm just
telling you men are stronger than women
I think that there is this idea this
crazy ideology especially among
Millennials that oh well you know men
generally are stronger than women but
look there are a lot of women could beat
up guys there are not a lot of women who
could beat up guys there were virtually
no women who could ever beat up any guy
it of people you know I don't know maybe
something like eight-year-old boy or
something but people who are vaguely in
the same
age-range it virtually can never happen
because men simply are stronger than
women this is a biological fact and
they're denying this biological fact and
I think it cracked political correctness
because I can look with my own two eyes
and I can see that a guy is not a woman
and that a woman is not a man and and
when you when that lie is exposed when
that essential lie is exposed all the
other ones for you think oh maybe
illegal aliens aren't really
undocumented dreaming dreamer sleeping
dreamers maybe a future or documented
American maybe those lot maybe it isn't
true maybe that falls apart I think
you're seeing the crack up of political
correctness and I would encourage people
we're talking about earlier president
Trump's political kind of gut reaction
look at where he goes on the issues I
think there you're gonna find where
people resonates strongly because he
doesn't think about politics from the
perspective of Edmund Burke or Russell
Kirk or Michael Oakshott or even Bill
Buckley or whatever he's thinking about
it from a really gut level from a media
level from an information level and what
did he focus on political correctness
immigration those are the big issues in
the 2016 campaign and we're still seeing
that really resonates with people the
lies of political correctness justice
injustice protecting our borders
protecting our country really good news
for Republicans from all of those polls
but look around because in the next 22
days you're gonna see polls get
manipulated try to suppress conservative
votes try to boost left-wing activism
and left-wing boats look around for that
because it is bound to happen but we
will be here drinking our powwow tears
our powwow Chow tears and smiling
because right now people should be
cautiously hopeful come back tomorrow in
the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Knowles show I will see you
know I won't see you tomorrow I'm giving
a speech tomorrow sorry I'll see you on
Wednesday
sorry you've gotta wait just Mull on
this mole on all of this wisdom for a
whole day or watch another Kingdom Sea
on Wednesday I'm Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
the michael noland is produced by seniya
Villarreal executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
our technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Jim nickel audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena
hair and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you